nearly 90 days after the president put
the vice president in charge of handling
the border crisis kamala harris is still
yet to go
dozens of house republicans have written
the president demanding
the removal of kamala harris from that
role and democratic texas congressman
henry cuellar
who told the faulkner focus last week he
asked the vice president to visit
says he's still trying still waiting
i've not heard from her office i have
talked to the white house my white house
contacts
uh but i've not heard from her and again
we're ready to help her
in any way this is not our first rodeo
we saw this uh
2014 under president obama 2019 under
president trump
there are people are just coming in and
as long as if we don't take those
incentives away
then they're just going to keep coming i
mean that's plain and simple
respect to representative cuellar but
come on this isn't like it was in 2014.
it hasn't looked like this in more than
20 years arizona attorney general mark
brnovich
uh great to have you on the program
first of all i want to get your reaction
to what we are learning
and finally hearing words that we never
wanted to hear never thought we would
they're done they're overwhelmed at this
point the border agents
yeah it's so disappointing here it's
because you know these folks are trying
to protect us
trying to protect the entire country and
if you talk to them they will tell you
that
not only do they feel overwhelmed but
they're demoralized because they feel
like they're actually
being punished for doing their job and
they're basically being told to ignore
the law
and to let people go and their law
enforcement officials i know in one of
our lawsuits
we depose the interim director of ice
here in phoenix and he talked about the
fact that
it's a danger to our community and
they're worried about the impact this is
going to have when you
don't deport people that are felons or
when the system is being overwhelmed the
people being
essentially decree the system being
decriminalized and incentivized to come
over here
it's demoralizing for all of them and
it's a threat to all of our communities
you know i just want to lean in just
quickly to remind everybody about those
lawsuits because they hear you
saying that you're suing and just
quickly catch us up on how that is
is unfolding so we actually in our
lawsuit that sued the bind
administration for their interim
guidance
their paws and deportations which
apparently now has become permanent
um we are waiting for a federal judge's
decision we're hoping we get that
decision every day
she was hard on the questioning she
recognized that there are people in
state
and federal custody that are being
released in our communities and the
biden administration had no answer for
what
why they're doing that and that is a
threat to danger our communities we're
waiting for that decision
we also have two other lawsuits going on
one of them regarding the public charge
rule
me and a couple of the other ag's have
petitioned the supreme court
to let us intervene to basically protect
that rule the trump administration
created that would stop
uh allowing benefits like housing and
welfare and other things
that are costing the american taxpayers
and we say incentivizing
illegal border crossings and then our
last lawsuit was related to the
immigration or the
environmental crisis that's being
created by all the people crossing the
border
well and i i want to tell everybody
there's another thing that's happening
axios is reporting this summer
president biden will end a trump era
rule that mandates sending family units
back to mexico
karl rove was talking about it i want
you to talk about it now
the attorney general brnovich of arizona
now what
is this rule how will it change when it
goes away how are we going to feel this
well title 42 is a federal statute and
what has happened during the trump
administration
they tried to limit the people coming
across the border where they could do
these
expedited removals based on the fact
that they could be a public threat of
health threat
to people in the country and we have
seen this last year with kovid
that you know we were told as americans
that we can't gather we have the social
distance we can't work you know go to
our workplaces
and yet the biden administration now has
these detention centers in fact a 1200
room hotel here in scottsdale arizona
where people are cramped together
and then being released into our
community so there is this potential
threat to the public health and safety
and the administration has some
discretion and
what i think we've seen harris is that
there's the old pottery barn rule that
if you break it you buy it
and i would submit to all your viewers
that the bite administration
is breaking the border they're
essentially destroying it and it's up to
them to fix it
and by them creating all these
incentives or making it harder for ice
to do its job
they are encouraging more and more
people to come here systems being
overwhelmed
on so many different levels and the
cartels are taking advantage of the
situation
yeah and and from our reporter bill
molution quote
no fear of being caught as these
smugglers come in
as and carrying all of these illegals
and our guys are protecting those
families from the smugglers i mean
it's it's an incredible thing that's
unfolding a.g thank you for being on the
program i appreciate it
thank you for watching